everyone welcome to this next episode of
your daily equation it may look a little
bit different from the place where I've
done the earlier episodes but actually
I'm in exactly the same spot it's just
that the rest of the room has gotten to
be so incredibly messy with all sorts of
stuff that I've had to shift my location
in order that you don't have to look at
the messy room that would otherwise be
behind me all right so with that little
detail out of the way today's episode
I'm gonna start in on one of the really
big ones the Big Ideas the big equations
Einstein's general theory of relativity
and just to give a little bit of context
to this let me just note myself Oh
different position I've got an angle
myself differently sorry I think that's
okay up on the screen good all right so
we're talking about general relativity
and to put this just in context of the
other big vital essential ideas that
really revolutionized our understanding
of the physical universe starting in the
20th century well I'd like to organize
those developments by writing down three
axes and these axes you can think about
say as the speed axis you can think
about it as the length axis and third
you can think about I cannot believe it
Siri just heard me that is so irritating
let's go away Siri Hey all right here
back to where it was yeah I have to
learn how to turn Siri off when I do
these things anyway the third axis is
the mass axis and the way to think about
this little diagram is that when you are
thinking about how the universe behaves
in the realms of extremely high speed
that takes you to Einstein's special
theory of relativity which it just will
have
since that is the subject that I started
with in this series of your daily
equation when you go to extremes along
the length axis and by extremes here I
really mean extremes of very small not
very big that takes you to quantum
mechanics which in some sense really is
the second major focus that I had in
this your daily equation series and now
we're on to the mass axis where when you
look at how the universe behaves at
extremely high masses that's where
gravity matters that takes you to the
general theory of relativity our focus
today okay so that's how things fit in
to that overarching organizational
scheme for thinking about the dominant
theories of the physical universe
and so let's now get in to the subject
of gravity the force of gravity and many
people believed not far after say the
late 1600s that the issue of gravity had
been completely sorted out by Isaac
Newton right because Newton gave us his
famous universal law of gravity
remember this is during the the Black
Death way back in the late 1600s Newton
retreats from Cambridge University goes
to his family's home in the safety of
the countryside there and in solitude
through really the amazing power of his
mental faculties and and creative ways
of thinking about how the world works he
comes up with this law universal law of
gravity that if you have two masses
let's say I have mass m1 and mass m2
that there is a universal force of
attraction between them acting to pull
them together
and the formula for that is a constant
Newton's gravitational constant M 1 M 2
divided by the square of their
separation so if their distance R apart
then you divide by R squared and the
direction of the force is along the line
connecting say their center center of
masses and that seemed to be the be-all
and end-all of the force of gravity in
terms of describing it mathematically
and indeed let me just just to get us
all on the same page here is a little
animation that shows Newton's law in
action so you have a planet like the
earth in orbit around a star like the
Sun and using that little mathematical
formula you can predict where the planet
should be at any given moment and you
look up into the night sky and the
planets are just where the math says
that they should be and we take it for
granted now but Wow
right think about think about the power
of of this little mathematical equation
to describe things that are happening
out there in space right so so
understandably rightly so there was a
general consensus that the force of
gravity was understood by Newton and his
universal law of gravity but then of
course other folks come into the story
and the person of course that I have in
mind here is Einstein and Einstein
begins to think about the force of
gravity and roughly 1907 or so and look
he comes to the conclusion that sure
Newton made great progress in
understanding the force of gravity but
the law that he gave us over here can't
really be the full story right why can't
it be the full story well you can
immediately catch the gist of Einstein's
reasoning by noting that in
this formula that Newton gave us there's
no time
variable there's there's no temporal
quality to that law why do we care about
that well think about it
if I was to change the value of the mass
then according to this formula the force
would immediately change so the force
felt over here at mass M - given by this
formula will immediately change if say I
change the value of M 1 in this equation
or if I change the separation if I move
M one this way making our a little
smaller or this way making our a little
bit bigger this guy over here is going
to immediately feel the effect of that
change immediately instantaneously
faster than the speed of light and
Einstein says there can't be that kind
of influence that exerts a change a
force instantaneously that's the issue
now small footnote some of you may come
back at me and say what about quantum
entanglement something that we discussed
in an earlier episode when we were
focusing our attention on quantum
mechanics you will recall that when I
discussed the spooky action of Einstein
we noted that there's no information
that's traveling from one entangled
particle to another there is an
instantaneous according to a given
reference frame correlation between the
properties of the two distant particles
this one's up and the other ones down
but there's no signal no information
that you can extract from that because
the sequence of results that the two
distant locations are random and
randomness doesn't contain information
so that's the end of the footnote but
bear in mind there really is a sharp
distinction between the gravitational
version of the instantaneous change in a
force versus the quantum mechanical
correlation from entangled particles all
right let me put that to the side so
Einstein realizes there's like a real
issue here and just to bring that issue
home let me show you a little example
here so imagine that you've got the
planets in orbit around the Sun and
imagine that
somehow I'm able to reach in and I pluck
the son out of space what will happen
according to Newton well Newton's law
says the force drops to zero if the mass
at the center goes away so the planets
as you see are immediately
instantaneously released from their
orbit so the planets instantaneously
feel the absence of the Sun a change in
their motion that is exerted
instantaneously from the changing mass
at the location of the Sun to the
location of the planets no good
according to Einstein so Einstein says
look perhaps if I understood better what
Newton had in mind regarding the
mechanism by which gravity exert its
influence from one place to another
Ison says maybe I would be able to
calculate the speed of that influence
and maybe with you know hindsight or or
better understanding a couple hundred
years later maybe on his time says to
himself I will be able to show that in
Newton's theory the force of gravity is
not instantaneous so Einstein goes to
check in on this and and he realizes as
many scholars had already realized that
Newton himself is kind of embarrassed by
his own universal law of gravity because
Newton himself realized that he had
never specified the mechanism by which
gravity exerts influence he said look if
you have the Sun and you have the earth
and they're separated by a distance
there is a force of gravity between them
and it gives us a formula for it but it
doesn't tell us how gravity actually
exerts that influence and therefore
there is no mechanism that Einstein
could analyze to truly figure out the
speed with which that mechanism for
transmitting gravity operates and
therefore he was stuck so Einstein sets
himself the goal of truly figuring out
the mechanism of how gravitational
influences are exerted from place to
place and he starts at about 1907 and
finally by 1915
he writes down the final answer in the
form of the equations of the general
theory of relativity and I'm gonna now
describe the basic idea which I think
many of you are familiar with of what
Einstein found and then I'll briefly
outline the steps by which Einstein came
to this realization and I'll finish up
with the mathematical equation that
summarizes the insights that Einstein
came to all right so for the general
idea Einstein says look if say you have
the Sun and the earth right and the Sun
is exerting an influence on the earth
what could be the source of that
influence well the puzzle is there's
nothing but empty space between the Sun
and the earth so Einstein ever the
capable genius to look at the most
obvious answer if there's only empty
space then it must be space itself space
itself that communicates the influence
of gravity now how can space do that how
can space exert any kind of influence at
all
Einstein ultimately comes the
realization that space and time can warp
and curve and through the curved shape
that can influence the motion of objects
right and so so the way to think about
it is imagine that space this is not a
perfect analogy but imagine space is
sort of like a rubber sheet or a piece
of spandex and when there's nothing in
the environment the rubber sheet is flat
but if you take a bowling ball say and
you put it in the middle of the rubber
sheet the rubber sheet will be curved
and then if you set marbles rolling
around on the rubber sheet or on the
spandex the marbles were now going to
curve trajectory because they're rolling
in the curved environment that the
presence of the of the bowling ball or
the shotput creates in fact you can
actually do this I did a little home
experiment with my kids you can see the
full video online if you like this from
a few few years ago but there you see it
we have a piece of spandex in our living
room and we have marbles that are
rolling around and that gives you a
sense
how the planets are nudged into orbit by
virtue of the curved space-time
environment through which they travel a
curved environment that the presence of
a massive object like the Sun can create
let me show you a more precise well not
more precise but a more relevant version
of this warp it so you can see it at
work in space so here you go so this is
grew this grid represents 3d space it's
a little hard to picture it fully so I'm
going to go to a a two dimensional
version of this picture that shows all
the essential ideas notice that space is
flat when there's nothing there but if I
bring in the Sun the fabric warps
similarly if I look in the vicinity of
the earth the earth 2 also warps the
environment and now focus your attention
on the moon because this is the point
the moon according to Einstein is kept
in orbit because it's rolling along a
valley in the curved environment that
the earth creates that is the mechanism
by which gravity operates and if you
pull back you see that the earth is kept
in orbit around the Sun for exactly the
same reason it is rolling around a
valley in the warped environment that
the Sun creates that's the basic idea
now look there are a bunch of subtleties
in here maybe I'll uh maybe I'll quickly
address them right now you could say to
me a hey look with the example of the
spandex which is the at-home version of
the Sun warping the fabric around it if
I put up of a bowling ball or a shot put
on a rubber sheet or a piece of spandex
the reason why it warps the spandex is
because the earth is pulling the object
downward but wait I thought we were
trying to explain gravity so our little
example now seems to be using gravity to
explain gravity what are we doing well
you're absolutely right
this metaphor this analogy
really needs to be thought of in the
following way it's not that we are
saying that Earth's gravity is causing
the environment to
or rather Einstein is telling us that a
massive energetic object merely by
virtue of its presence in space warps
the environment around it and by warping
the environment I mean warping the full
environment around it of course I have
difficulty showing that fully but
actually let me just give you this this
little visual here that you know it gets
partway toward it now you see that the
full 3d environment say is being warped
by the Sun it's harder to picture that
one and the 2d version is pretty good to
keep in mind but the 3d one is really
what's happening we're not looking at a
slice of space we're looking at the
entire environment being influenced by
the presence of a massive body within it
all right that that is the basic idea
and now I wasn't spend I want to spend
just a couple minutes on how it is that
Einstein came to this idea and it's
really it's really a two-step process so
step one Einstein realizes that there is
a deep and unexpected connection between
accelerated motion acceleration and
gravity and then he realizes that there
is another unexpected and beautiful
relationship between acceleration and
curvature curvy space times curvature
and the final step then of course will
be he realizes that there is a
connection therefore between gravity and
curvature so this link right over here
is forged if you will through
acceleration
being the common quality that leads you
both to an understanding of gravity and
understanding of curvature therefore a
link between gravity and curvature okay
so let me just quickly explain those
links the first of which happens in well
it was always there but Einstein
realized it in 1907 1907 Einstein is
still in the Patent Office in Bern
Switzerland he had the great success in
1905 with a special theory of relativity
but he still is working in the Patent
Office and he has one afternoon what he
calls the happiest thought of his entire
life
what is that happiest thought the Hat
happiest thought is he imagines a
painter who is painting the exterior of
a building on a hind ladder he matches
that painter falling off the ladder
falling off the roof and going into
freefall he doesn't take this thought
all the way to the impact to the ground
the impact is not his happiest thought
the happiest thought happens during the
journey why he realizes Einstein
realizes that the painter during this
descent will not feel his or her they
will not feel their own weight what do
you mean by that well I like to frame it
this way imagine that the painter is
standing on a scale that's velcroed to
their shoes and they're standing on the
scale on the ladder kind of a hard image
but imagine that they're now falling as
the painter Falls the scale Falls at the
same rate as the painter therefore they
fall together which means the painters
feet don't exert a push on the scale
they can't because the scale is moving
away at exactly the same rate as the
feet are moving downward too so looking
down at the reading on the scale that
painter will see that the reading drops
to zero painter feels weightless painter
does not feel their own weight now give
you a little example of that that again
this is sort of a annapolis
so general relativity but it do do it at
home physics right this is a dy I
version of the general theory of
relativity so how can you establish
without falling off the roof of a house
in a more safe manner how can you
establish that freefall this kind of
accelerated downward motion accelerated
downward motion can in some sense cancel
out the force of gravity well I did an
example of that on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert some years ago and they
did a nice job filming it so let me let
me show you the basic idea so imagine
you have a bottle filled with water and
it's got some holes in it the water
sprays out of the holes of the bottle of
course why does it do that because
gravity is pulling on the water and that
pull forces the water out of the holes
in the bottle but if you let the bottle
go into freefall like the painter the
water will no longer feel its own weight
without feeling that force of gravity
nothing will pull the water out of the
hole so the water should stop spraying
out of the holes and check this out
really does work all right here we go
during the descent look in slow-mo there
is no water spraying out of the holes
during that accelerated motion that
descent so this is what we mean here
about this relationship between
acceleration and gravity this is a
version where the accelerated downward
motion faster and faster as the bottle
of water or the painter Falls the force
of gravity is canceled if you will by
that downward motion you might say well
wouldn't you cancelled why is the bottle
falling why is the painter falling
that's gravity but I'm saying not from
our experience watching the painter fall
not from our experience watching the
bottle of water fall I'm saying that if
you put yourselves in the shoes of the
painter or you put yourselves in the
shoes of the bottle of water whatever
that means then from that perspective
the free-falling perspective from your
perspective in
that accelerated trajectory you don't
feel the force of gravity that's what I
mean
now the important point is that there's
also a reverse to this situation
accelerated motion can not only cancel
out gravity but accelerated motion can
mock up it can sort of fake a version of
gravity and it's a perfect fake again
what I mean by that well imagine that
you are floating in outer space so you
really are completely weightless right
and then imagine that someone causes you
to accelerate right they tie a rope to
you and they accelerate you say well
let's say they accelerate it like this
they accelerate you upward right and
imagine that they do that by putting a
platform under your feet so you're
standing on this platform in empty space
feeling weightless now they attach a
rope or crane whatever to a hook on the
platform on which you're standing and
that crane that hook that rope pulls you
upward as you're accelerating upward the
board under your feet you're gonna feel
it pressing against your feet and if you
close your eyes and if the acceleration
is correct you'll feel like you are in a
gravitational field because how does a
gravitational field say on planet Earth
feel how do you feel it you feel it by
virtue of the floor pushing up against
your feet and if that platform
accelerates upward you will feel that
pressing against your feet in the same
way if the acceleration is correct so
that's a version where accelerated
motion creates a force that feels just
like the force of gravity you've
experienced this and an airplane at this
beginning to taxi and it's about to take
off as it accelerates you feel pressed
back in your seat that feeling of being
pressed back you close your eyes and it
can sort of feel like you're lying down
the force of the seat on your back is
almost like the force you'd feel if
you're just a lying say on your back on
a couch so that's the link between
accelerated motion and gravity now for
part two of this so that's 90 nose
so for part two we need the connection
between acceleration and curvature and
this there are many ways I mean I it's
not the history is fascinating and again
it's mentioned before because I kind of
loved the piece we have this this stage
piece like Falls you can check it out
where we go through the whole history of
these ideas in a stage presentation but
there are actually a number of people
who contributed to thinking about
gravity in terms of curves released
Einstein's recognition of this and
there's one particularly beautiful way
of thinking about it that I like it's
called the ehrenfest paradox it's not
actually a paradox at all paradoxes are
usually when we don't understand things
at first and there is a seeming paradox
but ultimately we sort it all out but
sometimes the word paradox isn't removed
from the description and let me give you
this this example that gives us a link
between acceleration and curvature how
does it go
remember accelerated motion means a
change in velocity velocity is something
that has a speed and a direction so
there's a special kind of accelerated
motion where the speed the magnitude
doesn't change but the direction does
and what I have in mind here is circular
motion circular motion is a kind of
acceleration and I now like to show you
is that circular motion that accelerated
motion naturally gives us the
recognition that curvature must come
into play and the example I'm going to
show you is is a familiar ride you may
have been on it you know at an amusement
park or carnival it's often called the
tornado ride I described this in the
elegant universe but I'll show you a
visual in just a moment you know it's a
ride you you stand on the circular
platform that spins around and you
actually feel your body pressed against
a circular cage that is moving it's
attached to this circular platform and
that outward force that you feel I'm
making me strong enough that sometimes
they actually drop the bottom of the
ride out with you're standing on so you
just
hovering there and sometimes in midair
but your body is pressed by the circular
motion against the cage and there's
enough friction hopefully that you don't
slip away and fall alright that's the
setup here's here's the issue all right
so here is this circular ride imagine
that you measure the circumference of
this ride from the outside not on the
right itself so you lay out these rulers
and whatever you find I think in this
case there are twenty-four rulers
twenty-four feet you can also measure
the radius and you can get a number for
that as well and indeed if you look at
the relationship between the
circumference and the radius you will
find that C equals two pi R just as we
all learned in junior high school but
now imagine measuring this from the
perspective of someone on the ride
itself the accelerated observer well
when they measured the radius they're
going to get the exact same answer
because that's moving perpendicular to
the motion no Lorentz contraction but if
you measure the circumference look what
happens the rulers are all
instantaneously moving in the direction
of the motion so that you're all
shrunken contracted therefore it takes
more of those rulers to go all the way
around in this particular case I just
imagine that it's 48 of those rulers 48
rulers for the circumference equals 48
radius is unchanged again that's moving
perpendicular to the instantaneous
direction of the motion which is all in
the circumferential direction right
radius is going this way circumference
is going that way so there's no change
in the measurement of the radius which
means C will no longer equal to PI R you
say itself what how can see not equal to
PI R what does that mean well when you
learned that C equals 2 PI R you were
talking about circles that were drawn on
a flat surface it must therefore be the
case that from the perspective of the
person on the ride laying out those
little rules and feeling that
gravitational force right there
accelerating that feel that force
pulling them outward from their
perspective it must be that
circle is not flat must be curved it
must be the case you know sort of a
poetic image of this of you will over
here kind of dolly esque picture those
circles are warped they're curved
clearly C will not equal to PI R for
those particular warped shapes so that's
kind of an artistic version of it but
the conclusion is that the accelerated
motion of the ride which we know gives a
connection to gravity also gives a
connection to curvature so then that is
the linkage that we were looking at the
accelerated motion from the circle gives
rise to the feeling of a gravitational
like force that accelerated motion gives
rise to measurements from the
perspective of the person experiencing
that acceleration that do not satisfy
the usual rules of flat Euclidean
so-called geometry and therefore we
learned that there is a connection
between gravity and curvature and now I
can bring back the image that we had
before with a little more insight from
that description so again here is flat
3d space when there's no matter go to
the 2-dimensional version just so we can
picture it bring in a massive body like
the Sun and now that gravity gives rise
to this curvature and again the moon why
does it move around the moon in some
senses is being nudged around by the
curvature in the environment or said
another way the moon is seeking out the
shortest possible trajectory we called
geodesics we'll come to this and that
short as possible trajectory in that
curved environment yields the curved
paths that we would call a planet going
in to orbit that's the basic chain of
reasoning that leads on Stein to this
picture all right so then what is the
equation um
just gonna write down the equation and
subsequently subsequent episodes I'm
gonna just in this episode be satisfied
to just give you the basic idea and show
you the equation I will unpack the
equation later on but what is the
equation well Einstein in November of
1915 at Elektra the Prussian Academy of
Science writes down the final equation
which is our mu nu minus 1/2 G mu nu R
equals 8 pi G over C to the fourth times
T mu nu what in the world does that all
mean well this part over here is the
mathematical mathematical the
mathematical still early for me the
mathematical way of talking about curve
that sure ok and this fella over here is
the way you talk about energy and mass
also momentum but we call it mass energy
one since we learn in special relativity
that mass and energy are two sides of
the same coin
you recognize that mass is not the only
source I mean that clumpy object like
the earth is not the only source for
gravity energy more generally is a
source for gravity and that is captured
by that expression over here T mu nu
I'll describe this not today
but in a subsequent episode and that is
Einsteins equation for the general
theory of relativity not to really
understand this equation you need to
understand all of these gadgets that we
have here the Ricci tensor the scalar
curvature you need to understand the
Riemann curvature tensor to understand
those this is the metric on
space-time you need to understand that
and I really do mean space-time in fact
we're talking about the gravitational
pull of a planet like the earth or the
Sun the imagery that I showed you with
the Warped environment you know it helps
your mental thinking about things but in
the usual way the
we set up our coordinates it's actually
the warping of time not really the
warping of space that's the dominant
influence in causing an object to fall
whether I drop an object here or whether
it's the moon perpetually falling toward
the earth as it moves in the tangential
direction thereby keeping itself in
orbit so time is is really quite
important to this you can't just think
in spatial terms at all but to
understand all those mathematical
details we have to unpack the the
mathematics if you will of differential
geometry I will do a little bit of that
in subsequent episodes but I hope this
gives you a feel for the basic insight
of the general theory of relativity why
it is that Einstein came to this
realization that gravity necessarily
involved a curvature of space don't keep
that tornado ride in mind again no
analogies are perfect but it does help
you catch the essential links between
say accelerated motion and gravity the
water drop the painter between
accelerated motion and curvature the
tornado ride and then it's the genius of
Einstein it puts it all together as we
will see and unpack in subsequent
episodes okay that's all I wanted to do
today that is your daily equation until
we meet next time looking forward to
that until then take care